je m'appelle pound madame
elle est partout avec moi je m'occupe du
nord de 250 chamelles et leurs petits
[Musique]
je les ai tous vu naître mais ils m'ont
toujours vu là
mes frères disent que je suis le père de
chameaux
[Musique]
à la naissance les chameaux n'ont pas de
cette force pour atteindre le Big normal
je suis là pour que mes chameaux soient
forts
[Musique]
en perçant les balais veut dire qu'il
dit mais nous ne sommes pas des guides
pour les hommes nous sommes des guides
pour les chameaux
[Musique]
j'avais 12 ans quand j'ai quitté mon
village pour conduire cette horde avec
mon père et aujourd'hui c'est la plus
grande du Rajasthan et les meilleurs
chameaux mes frères et moi on est connu
pour ça
chaque année pour prouver que nos
chameaux sont les plus endurants et les
plus rapides un de nous trois traverses
le grand désert pour aller au
rassemblement de chameliers il montre le
chameau qu'il préfère
en fait depuis des années c'est moi qui
traverse le désert avec
demain mes frères partiront au
rassemblement
ils suivront la route qui contourne le
désert
moi je vais tout droit au cœur des
sables là où il n'y a pas de route
pendant mon voyage m'a ordre reste ici
et ne bougera pas à cause des
nouveaux-nés j'en ai eu 60 cette année
et il en reste à venir
celle-là est pour bientôt mais je sais
qu'elle attendra mon retour
elles attendent toujours mon retour
il n'y a que des chamelles dans ma Horde
et un seul chameau
je ne peux pas garder les jeunes mal dès
qu'ils ont deux ans ils se battent j'en
ai 40 cette année
ils partiront avec mes frères
[Musique]
cette année mes frères ne veulent pas
que je parte ils disent que je suis trop
vieux pour traverser les sables
mais je partirai quand même
ma meilleure amie elle me conduira
[Musique]
la porte du désert
après ces murs commencent le tal le pays
des sables
plus d'eau
[Applaudissements]
dans cette citadelle vu l'homme qui
n'oublie pas tous les chameliers
viennent l'écouter il raconte l'histoire
de notre tribu
[Musique]
au début le dieu Shiva a créé le chameau
et puis il a créé le premier homme de ma
tribu pour s'occuper de ce chameau le
premier chameau avait cinq pattes en
voyant ça le premier homme a demandé
comment le chameau pourrait-il marcher
avec une patte sous le ventre
alors Shiva a pris dans sa main la
cinquième patte et la remontée en l'air
ça que les chameaux ont une bosse
et il a dit que nous étions là pour
prendre soin de ce chameau
[Musique]
dans le désert il n'y a pas de
différence entre les hommes
dans le désert c'est le chameau qui fait
la différence
raita ne portera 7 jours à travers les
dunes si notre chemin est droit nous
trouverons la cité de la reine du désert
et derrière elle le grand rassemblement
[Musique]
ici tout bouge tout se déplace d'un jour
à l'autre on ne reconnaît plus le visage
du désert
là autant d'hommes se sont déjà perdus
[Musique]
elle peut tenir 5 jours sans boire
Sylvain s'arrête
[Musique]
le jour où une chamelle a un petit et ne
pense plus qu'à lui
elle devient incapable de conduire le
nord elle perd sa souplesse et sa
fidélité
c'est pour ça que d'enfant j'avais trop
besoin d'elle
les lèvera
les frères ont raison
je deviens vieux c'est notre dernier
voyage
[Musique]
j'étais un enfant quand mon père
m'emmenait vivre avec sa horde
au début j'étais perdu au milieu de tous
ces chameaux j'ai dû m'habituer à boire
de l'eau sous matre à dormir seul dans
le froid
[Musique]
et puis mon père m'a appris à les
reconnaître elle est compter le temps
d'un regard alors parler avec la gorge
et un jour il m'a dit l'homme vit au ras
du sol quand il monte à chameau il
décolle
[Musique]
la cité de la reine du désert
le
on raconte que la peste a dévasté ses
murs
les habitants ont accusé les rats
alors une femme est venue
elle a rassemblé les enfants morts et
les a transformé en rat pour leur rendre
la vie
elle a dit qu'il serait ses enfants et
que toute vie doit être respectée même
celle des rats l'épidémie s'est arrêtée
et pour la remercier on lui a construit
un temple
pour notre famille elle est devenue la
déesse du désert celle qui protège les
enfants contre la maladie
[Musique]
elle a dit que les hommes et les animaux
sont tous ses enfants
[Musique]
tels qui veille sur mes chameaux
le grand rassemblement toutes les tribus
s'y retrouve chaque année à la première
lune d'avril
[Musique]
les chefs se réunissent écoute les
plaintes rendent justice et partage leur
territoire
les familles marient leurs enfants et
aussi leur plus beaux animaux les
histoires qu'on raconte deviennent vite
des légendes
les tribus viennent là depuis des
siècles c'est le seul endroit où il y a
ces dos pour 100.000 animaux
sous le sable coule un grand fleuve et
il ne s'est jamais arrivé
[Musique]
il y a des caravaniers des bergers des
marchands toutes les races de bétail et
toutes les familles qui vivent de
l'élevage
chaque tribu a sa réputation
pour ce qui est des chameaux c'est notre
famille que l'on vient voir et c'est mon
vieux frère qui parle
[Musique]
les hommes pensent que la solitude du
désert est terrible mais pour moi la
vraie solitude est ici
je n'ai pas de vie en dehors de ma Horde
[Musique]
mes frères disent que je devrais rentrer
au village qu'un jour il faut arrêter de
suivre les chameaux
[Musique]
tant que j'aurai assez de force pour
aider un chameau à venir au monde
je resterai là
[Musique]